hello everybody and welcome to another
episode of ask mr. wonderful who's my
guest this is fantastic it's Gus winner
son of young winner founder of Rolling
Stone magazine cultural icon rock and
roll music fashion politics you name it
so much to talk about with Gus fantastic
but I thought because it's our rock and
roll kind of vibe and you know we're
only stones over 50 years old now
Gus is running the show I thought we'd
go back in time a little bit and I want
to add the music to this week's episode
just the background track but in those
days rock and roll and this is a classic
a 69 Telecaster and this is such an
unforgiving [ __ ] of a guitar to play
with yet iconic a lot of people don't
know that this was the guitar that
played all of those solos on the first
Led Zeppelin album that's right
it's amazing and also you think of all
the licks that Keith Richards played you
know on the early Rolling Stones when he
did an open G on a telly with the top e
missing the string gone did five string
licks really really interesting but
let's leave that in the past I want to
talk about the classic rock and roll
tune most of the power chords in that
day were sort of like three chord
wonders like 80% of the songs were done
this like that classic psychedelic riff
it was kind of
[Music]
remember that one
it's like fifty songs but then along
comes jimi hendrix and he does something
really interesting he gets much more
complicated a lot more chords a lot of
miners a lot of interesting transitions
and i think the song that i want to try
and lay down today is my version of
little weighing which is so been done so
many times and everybody rifts to it a
different way and i thought it would be
perfect for the gus interview so you
remember that one it was kind of like
[Music]
and so on its own I just screwed that up
right there but then you know maybe a
little lead ladies and gentlemen
Gus winter CEO of Rolling Stone
[Music]
anyways look Gus let's talk about how
you've been hanging out for the last
four or five weeks how was your mindset
been and everybody's asking the same
question about everybody else so where
are you at well I'm in a very fortunate
place in terms of location and space and
I've been worried about all people out
there I was in New York initially which
I've never felt the city have that kind
of energy and it's jarring when you
watch the news and it's it's some of the
scariest stuff you've ever seen in a way
but I've been fortunate to be with my
family and been trying to enjoy that
time together but obviously you know
managing a business through this type of
crisis is extremely difficult and
stressful and then also figuring out
what role we can play to be part of the
solution I don't know if you saw our
cover yesterday with Andrew Cuomo on it
we're gonna get to that don't worry
you're venomous a bit of a [ __ ]
disturber here I got to tell you so
we've done some amazing things through
all this in terms of reporting I mean
our our traffic has never been Hindmarch
we have 36 million unique visitors on
our site which was the biggest monthly
of our had prior to that I think 34
million and April will surpass that with
some margins so we've got an important
role to play here as a news delivery
service as a perspective on the world as
a connector to important people and
voices and all of this we've had some
incredible interviews had one with
Stacey Abrams we put up online and full
and video we had one Budaj edge we had
one with Sam B we just covering the
gamut we've also launched a couple
series and franchises that have been
great we did one called in my room
where we have musicians performing from
their room from their space all over the
world we launched it with Brian Wilson
we've had some incredible artists
performed in that series so it's been
about managing through crisis obviously
managing expenses and making sure all
our employees are ok we've got certain
you know people alone in apartments in
small cities so just checking in with
them every day and and all that but then
from a creative perspective figuring out
how we can use this to to propel
everything we're doing so we knew you
know we were gonna do this interview so
I put out to my social look if you have
questions for Gus winter this is your
chance and you know I set it up to four
million people so we got a lot more
questions that we could possibly curate
so we tried to take you know bunches of
them but the one that is every second
question Gus is how the [ __ ] do I get on
the cover of Rolling Stone which is some
kind of a cultural thing that has been
around for 50 years tell me what the
cover of The Rolling Stone means to you
you're the new steward of it but you
know what it meant from 50 years back
it's a big deal it's a huge deal how do
you choose the cover of The Rolling
Stone and you just did it this week a
very controversial one a lot of politics
and what you did there you're kind of
shoving it in the president's face in
some ways but you did it anyways how do
you choose the cover
that's the question well from a process
standpoint there's a group of people our
chief editorial and creative staff and
we get together and brainstorm ideas and
think about what is gonna have the most
cultural impact what we believe in the
most but it's a snapshot in time it's a
snapshot in time yeah I mean listen I
did you ever watch the Rolling Stone
documentary on HBO that Alex Gaylord is
I love rolling stone I grew up with the
so I randomly rewatched it last night
because
my friend that's out here with us was
asking my mom all these questions about
her life and she started talking and the
stories are so incredible so we ended up
watching the documentary again which I
hadn't seen in two years probably and
it's just so astounding to wrap my head
around what my mom and dad did and what
they created and mostly just the moment
that they were in in San Francisco in
the late 60s I mean they were literally
my dad was at Berkeley when the Free
Speech Movement was happening and you
had rock and roll kind of forming like
it really the story begins kind of
Monterey Pop where you had Otis Redding
and Janis Joplin and Jimi Hendrix and
everyone kind of forming their their
sound and this movement what ended up
changing the world multiple times over
in one small confined space in San
Francisco at that time and they my
parents were right in the middle of it
and my dad's vision behind it his big
insight was that not only was this music
great and fun and something that young
people wanted to be a part of and
listened to but it had a broader
cultural importance that would have
major effects on society on politics on
just progressive ideals and flow
permeate all of culture all of American
culture and eventually the world so
drinking that in and understanding what
type of impact rolling stone and roll
rolling stone played through all of it
is it's almost hard to comprehend so
today when we think about what is a
cover there are a lot of different
factors and objectives but I think at
its core it's is this subject is this
image have the ability to be something
that is iconic that as you said captures
a time and moment so that is the chief
number one criteria we think about in
choosing what the cover subject should
be who should shoot it
and what type of story we want to tell
how big a weight is the legacy of where
where only stone magazine came from on
you because it's not just you know what
occurred in those days and and you know
how it really captured the beginning of
the Beatles and The Rolling Stones and
all the bands you mentioned that part of
Monterey that was defined as true rock
and roll classic rock and roll today
but music today is no weird even near
what that was because it was such a
concentration of styles maybe ten bands
ruled all the sales of albums back then
now you have a plethora of different
styles and people and personalities and
geographies and and your mandate is to
try and Chronicle that how do you do it
I think you you go where the quality is
and if you look at our last 24 covers
for example if the subjects are ranging
from you know political figures to music
figures of all genres I mean just to two
issues ago we had scissor on the cover
with Megan missed out Megan Italian and
normanni
together and like that's something that
I think a lot of people be like
surprised by or certainly a couple years
ago shocked by so we we've pushed the
boundaries as much as we can we continue
to look for how we can push it to make
this thing as kind of important with
what matters to young people today and
what matters to culturally engage people
today as possible and you know it spans
it ranges across the spectrum of
musicians politicians actors but they
all have to kind of have a level of
cultural importance that we believe in
so the magazine business from the 70s
where the majority of profits came from
selling advertising on a print format
you know the demise of that has been
chronicled a thousand times print print
is is not that relevant to a new
generation that you're talking about
online is in what ways if you have to
change the way you think of that
business because I mean it goes back to
how heavy a burden is the past of what
the Rolling Stone brand is to how you
you actually work day to day do you have
to keep going back and saying yourself
what would they have done what would my
father gone done in the 70s versus what
I'm doing today or or do you just think
of it as a brand-new I have a new future
with this thing I have the legacy of a
brand which is a huge benefit obviously
I mean everybody knows in music what
Rolling Stone was and is how do you
manage it because you still have a print
version but that cannot be an easy way
to make money and yet translating
digital advertising over from print has
not been easy to a lots and lots of
others that have tried it you're still
around but a lot of compete roots in the
70s are no longer viable they're gone
yeah I mean since I came into the
business which I graduated school in
2012 and then started working at the
company I've always felt like the
mindset has been kind of a startup
within this iconic legacy and brand what
when I joined the website had like I
don't know four million visitors uni
visitors a month and as I just mentioned
we're now up to like near 40 million so
and that's not counting or reach across
social media and all these other areas
so it's about taking the mission and the
ethos of what was created and
translating that to what we must do
today to grow and our ambitions are not
just to survive they're to build
something enormous on a global scale and
we are making quite a bit of progress in
doing so obviously relying on print
advertising is failing strategy so we
have made massive changes to our whole
business model
we've gone from a biweekly to a monthly
in terms of our print we've taken I mean
I think you buy a lot of magazines down
they almost feel like they're printed on
like toilet paper I mean this the the
quality is so thin so we've gone the
opposite direction said once a month
we're gonna put out almost book like
product and we took our size of the
magazine up to a hundred pages where
previously it was like in the 60s or 70s
we put it on the oversized paper stock
really high quality paper and we fill it
with our best reporting and photography
and it's a great medium to kind of swim
in our best stuff but the thrust of what
we do is online and we have radically
changed how we think and operate as a
editorial team and as a business to
really be like a news driven culture I
mean we publish about 60 to 70 stories a
day now which obviously prior to the
importance of digital it was just
putting out a magazine every two weeks
and I'm a much radically different
operation but beyond that we're focused
on building our events business and
really establishing that as a revenue
stream we see a lot of potential there
and we've done really good work to grow
it over the last couple years we do now
like twenty to thirty events a year we
did last year kind of a different size
and scale but we are still primarily in
the advertising business digital
advertising events advertising print
advertising to a lesser degree and we're
very focused on how we can harness
everything that we have built and are
building into other areas outside of
advertising so there's obvious routes
like subscription which we're deep into
developing right now a digital
subscription but also licensing and
product development so we we are not
trying to boil the ocean per se but
we're trying to and are heavily pursuing
new areas where we can take our magic
and build real businesses around them
let me ask you a question that comes
from the journalism side of this
business when one of the challenges
every entity that's going from print to
digital given that how much content
you're generating the frequency of
issuance going up and up how do you
curate your content how do you fact
check it how do you make sure you know
the Rolling Stones got in trouble before
it was an incident recently I don't have
to detail it but every publication has
suffered this - the street cred of
journalism has declined probably because
of the the the issues around politics in
the last couple of elections but do you
worry that when someone puts out you
know an article for you and and they did
it in 48 hours that you have enough time
to check the information I mean we
probably have one of the most rigorous
fact-checking processes you'll find and
you were alluding to an incident where
we took our eye off the ball there and
coming out of that we said to ourselves
like we we will never make this mistake
again and as you said it most major
journalistic operations have dealt with
this in some regard in their history the
Washington Post of our times so it's
critical to us that all every story we
put up goes through a process of of
fact-checking and copy editing and line
editing I don't think a lot of people a
lot of digital publishers and upstarts
or legacy publishers will survive long
term I think there's gonna be a few that
have an even bigger opportunity to grow
what they do think you look at the New
York Times and they've done an
outstanding job of finding a new model
that they're building upon new ways of
packaging what they do
so being of quality is priority number
one without that if used if you water
down your product to try and satisfy
kind of short
goals I think it's would be deathly to a
publishing business but when you stray
into politics and I think it's fair to
say Rolling Stone leans a little bit to
the left maybe you can argue that with
me but I certainly read it and have for
decades and it has it has had a left
bias that means 50 percent of the
population even though they want to get
their music news from you put up with a
view that they don't agree with do you
worry that blending politics with music
the music is universal generally
speaking transcends partisanship but
politics does not Gus and some of your
articles rile the right and do you feel
you're at risk of losing subscriptions
you losing eyeballs because you for you
know lack of a better world pissed off
50% of the voters know I think it's our
duty to cover politics like I said in
the beginning the founding principle
like literally the mission statement
that my dad wrote in issue one was this
isn't just about the music it's about
the values and I'm not quoting
word-for-word
the values and principles that the music
embraces and if you look at the history
of political activism through music it's
enormous
so covering politics is is a critical
part of our mission that said we we do
lean left we get behind the issues that
are of most important to us in our
worldview and many of the musicians that
we cover our last our last issue had
Greta thon berg on the cover and was
solely dedicated to the environment as a
issue and topic and some incredible
reporting from some of our best
journalists but it is important to
capture multiple perspectives
we have journalists that come from all
different sides and
backgrounds and worldviews but yes we
have a general philosophy about the
world and we believe in it and and we
want to make an impact in how some of
those issues are thought of and and
treated and and how people are taking
action on certain things that think the
environment is a really good example of
that it's a good segue into another
question I have for you I have at least
a hundred people a lot of them just
graduating from journalists colleges or
you know have interests in what you do
in their early 20s they want to know
what you're looking for and who you
employ so if you were to give a
universal metric because I mean
countless questions ask them what it
takes to get a job at Rolling Stone it's
that simple
what does it take to get a job at
Rolling Stone well I think that it
ultimately boils down to
are you more passionate about something
than someone else I mean there's there
are endless amounts of really smart
talented people out there and I think
whether you're trying to get a job as a
journalist of Rolling Stone or or
anywhere if you have an actual passion
for something you love something you
will probably work harder and be more
committed to being greater than that
thing than anyone else for the majority
of other people so I think that that is
the biggest factor in finding a great
talent is like they believe in the thing
in what they're doing in what we stand
for in our mission in the role of
journalism that and that comes in all
sorts of different forms and shapes and
sizes I mean probably the thing that
strikes me most in rewatching the
documentary and thinking about the whole
legacy is just the incredible talent
that has been part of Rolling Stones
roster over the years I mean Hunter
Thompson and Leibovitz Tom Wolfe the
list is pretty much endless and today we
have extraordinarily talented people and
you know it's not like everyone
you know there's one formula I mean some
of these people are insane
but in great ways and that makes them
legends but I would say you know passion
and belief mixed with real skill and
talent is the best way to get a job
wrong sir there you have a unique view
from what you're from your perch of the
music industry which is going through
some trauma right now because the in the
last you know - digitization of music
the business model of selling the vinyl
record changed the actual economics of
what artists make changed and there was
a very dark period there for a while in
the mid 80s when it was very tough to
make a living because your primary
source of $1 or $2 a record turned into
5 cents for a digital you know mp3
ripped off file or whatever through all
of the transitions that it's gone
through and then Along Came performance
and all of a sudden a huge resurgence in
performance and merchandising and the
unique experience of gathering watching
a band and a giant venue it came roaring
back and it was peaking and the industry
consolidated Live Nation is a major
player now obviously and then all of a
sudden like that it's turned off you
can't do that now what is the new normal
in your view going to be when people can
gather together again is that business
going to change is everybody gonna have
a mask on what's what what does a rock
concert gonna look like what does any
concert going to look like well I think
you've got you've got two things sort of
at odds with one another the first is I
don't know how comfortable people are
gonna feel gathering in massive Graham
you look at festivals and I've been
talking to a wide range of people in
that business over the last week two
weeks people wanting to gather with you
know
anywhere from 30 to 80 thousand other
people in a small essentially confined
space I don't know how comfortable
people be doing that until there's an
established vaccine and that could take
18 months right until the vaccines there
and available so I think until that
point it is gonna be different and
there's a major question mark on how how
the public is gonna want to gather for a
rock show or sporting event or anything
in the live business but inherently we
are social people and live music is one
of the great joys of life or a sporting
event so I believe that long term that
will win out people's drive to want to
be together and be social and interact
and watch incredible performances I mean
why else are we here other than to do
things like that but I think it's gonna
take a little time and I think until a
vaccine is out there it's gonna be tough
for anyone in that business and it's
miraculous
how much of it Live Nation owns and I
think there's a major question mark
around what what they will do and how
their business will look over the next
18 months but long term I have a strong
belief that there's no way people won't
be back to going to shows regularly so
the rolling stone brand over the decades
is chronicled some of the most iconic
concerts in history that defined whole
careers and genres of music etc when you
look at how the industry's changed
assuming you're correct and it comes
back to a normal see in the next two
years or whatever
where does rolling stone play a part in
that but what's your game plan you're
gonna use your brand in any way and you
see yourself fitting into that part of
music because just cash flows in the
music business have certainly moved in
that direction
great performance artists are doing very
well again in a way they never could
during a very peeking digital period in
the 80s they're back and they're they're
back big time where do you fit in that
give me the question want one other way
essentially how are we gonna fit in from
a survey industry perspective yeah
performance artists that are able to
sell tickets at extraordinary prices
today
to both even legacy acts even even acts
that were relevant in the 70s are doing
it and you knew artists like Billy Alice
can sell out anything anywhere with
extraordinarily rich ticket prices
that's a source of revenue rolling stone
traditionally hasn't tapped into do you
have any plans on being part of that
with your brand is that part of what
you're thinking of doing and if so how
yeah I mean we I want to have a true
music festival
Rolling Stone Music Festival I'm
currently looking at probably five or
six different scenarios where we enter
that part of the business that you're
describing like I said about the cover
and our journalism the key thing is is
there an opportunity where we can be
great at something and for years I both
kind of resent my dad about this but
also admire him for it every type of
thing you could imagine was thrown at
him out do wrong Center Hotel do this
through that and his philosophy was I am
in his mind he was the best editor in
the world and that's the thing that he
could be great at and deliver to the
audience and you know at the highest
level and he always stuck to it and I
think it's why the thing has been around
for 52 years now we are in a moment
where expanding into other areas is
critical so as I said the live business
will be a big part of our strategy over
the next five years and I'm currently in
the trenches of building that and figure
out exactly what our place in it is your
dad took a tremendous amount of
criticism in the later decades for not
expanding the brand
not not being enough of an opportunist
having built such a huge brand in music
and not doing exactly what you just said
they're not expanding it I'm just
wondering you you were old enough then
to understand that kind of pressure and
you know and I've had many people ask me
about you and whether from that context
from the way they looked at it if you
won't make that same mistake if you if
you believe that the vision has to be so
defined is so narrow and remain the
greatest editor which that's great you
even you've increased the digital which
I'm not by the way well I got it you
have fantastic talent that's clear
you've said that but big big brands are
successfully managed you can look at
polo you can look at clothing you can
look at other industries people are
sometimes extraordinarily successful
expanding it and curating it as they do
it where do you fit in that continuum
are you your father's son in the context
of focus or are you gonna have a bigger
vision for this thing
no I if we don't expand if we think
narrowly we fail period we're not in an
era where narrow thinking in the media
business will succeed now our great
strengths in terms of journalism
journalism and storytelling will always
lead everything we do and keep us
relevant and important and if we drop
the ball on that aspect of it it would
have really terrible ramifications on
everything else for trying to do but the
vast majority of my time and energy and
certainly passion for this thing is how
can we take that and create a very
sizeable global business that is leading
the world in terms of content creation
across the board so that's films it's
television that's print of course it's
digital
it's online it's news now trying to take
on too much would be a mistake but by
all means my perspective is to be as
aggressive in a smart way as aggressive
as possible about growth and taking what
we do and what we mean to the world and
growing it okay before we leave the past
I have one more here and it's again one
of these questions that's at the top of
the list by many people they want to
know what your relationship with your
father is like now what's that like are
you willing to talk about it we're
extremely close he's he's my best friend
we talk every single day he in so many
ways is my chief counsel I mean he also
taught me the importance of seeking out
smart people he said to me at one point
he's like one of the great pleasures and
advantages of what you do and the
position you're in is to be able to meet
with and learn from some of the smartest
people in the world that are doing the
most interesting things and I took that
to heart very early on and spend so much
time just seeking out super impressive
people I mean Rapinoe from Live Nation
is one of them who recently I spent time
with and just just in and there's so
many across the board who taught me so
much and giving me so many ideas and
just to bounce things off of but I've
come to realize in all of that that my
dad for better or worse is is one of the
most interesting smart wisest people out
there so having him at my disposal to
bounce things off of and learn from
every day even though we disagree on all
sorts of stuff and yell at each other
all the time I mean I just feel
fortunate and I take advantage of it I'd
be silly not to and you know he's
hilarious so we we laugh a lot okay
let's get to some questions Gus because
I could not possibly
post all the questions we got so we
tried to curate down to a few that
captured the essence of the hundreds and
hundreds you're a popular guy a lot of
people want to hear what you have to say
so I'm gonna just pick some eclectic
ones you'll hear them and you can answer
they're different okay here we go
this one's from Melanie let's hear from
Melanie here hi mr. wonderful
this is melody have you ever found
yourself waking up in the morning
wanting to say just [ __ ] it and to
escape the day's task at hand if so how
did you mentally get yourself back on
track for the day thank you I thought
this was a relevant question given the
world we're living in right now do you
wake up
Gus and say [ __ ] it I just don't want to
get out of bed today I don't think I've
ever said that I can't I wake up and my
mind is like racing sometimes I have
trouble falling asleep I've been taking
ZZ quill lately I'm getting flack for my
family for it because the name is so
insane sounding but no I do great
pleasure in life is to get up and go and
create and deal with people and and you
know put your energy towards something
good so I have not mice I know a lot of
people do that and it's an issue that is
serious and and there's light versions
of it and really intense versions of it
and I've had people in my life that have
span the spectrum both but me personally
I don't suffer from [ __ ] syndrome good
answer
all right let's hear from somebody else
let's hear from Brad here hey mr.
wonderful my name is Brad Clark and I'm
interested in asking you and Gus what
you guys think is a good way to build a
community around a brand obviously Gus
had to do that with his Rolling Stones
issues and thought this would be a great
opportunity to ask you guys that love
the show thank you you know Gus that's a
great question because you said you had
a few million followers when you took
over digitally and now you're talking
about a quantum of that
thirty forty million how did you do that
key distinction I was referring to
unique visitors which are people that
come to our website over the course of a
month so and the reason I'm I make that
distinction is because the follower on
social media much different thing a
unique visitor someone coming to read
our output in journalism but both very
very important so if you combine the two
we are reaches somewhere around seventy
plus million in a given month that's a
better number it's a better number but
how did you do it that's a quantum of
where the business was 2012 2013 2014
certainly that was the beginning of the
digital you know wave if you want to
call it that it was coming fast I mean
it took a real culture change within our
staff and our team we came from a very
print driven background that wasn't
really growing the online audience
because they weren't thinking that way
and they weren't that wasn't driving the
creative process so anyone who comes
from publishing and a legacy publishing
brand or magazine or newspaper I think
has experienced this you know and it's
it's tough getting a editorial team and
a business team to actually change their
thinking and process and figuring out
who is capable of doing that and who
just won't won't really get on board so
we've had to make a lot of staff changes
over the years percentage do you think
you turned over to turn it into digital
versus print I mean it must have been
brutal
but are they half gone or two-thirds or
where what where are you on that lots of
lots of turnover but less turnover than
you think in the key positions so our
editorial team
the the editorial leaders many of them
have been with the Brantford over ten
years in some cases you know close to 20
in terms of and and that's because the
the creative mechanism at the top that I
don't think changes that much and you've
got smart people it's not rocket science
to understand how to sort of take
something and put it in into digital
format and what will work there versus
and these are extraordinarily talented
editors we're talking about but in terms
of the people lower down we just need a
pace and an energy and you asked like
how did we build that audience frankly
by putting a lot of good content out
regularly and just changing our Payson
and our energy and our daily mix around
how we operate and what we produce in
the sheer volume of it while maintaining
quality so we've had an enormous amount
of turnover editorially less turnover at
the top though there's been some but a
lot of turnover in those mid mid levels
and more junior levels and then on a
business side we've essentially turned
over the entire team so you need to
music you know talking about journalism
in News newsmakers come and go
politicians get elected and they drop
off newsmakers stories break every day
editors deal with people that come and
flash to the surface and then they're
gone that's not quite what happens in
music a great artist that has a
multi-decade career the relationship
with that person must be a huge asset to
Rolling Stone access to these people as
they become beyond famous that become
part of culture and and iconic in their
own societies is that one of the reasons
that you don't that you have some people
that have been there 20 years they just
have a value in terms of their
relationships with musicians yeah
absolutely I mean access is a key part
of everything we do and our offering I
mean you mentioned Billy Eilish earlier
we had bill
on the cover right around the Grammys
it's past year and we had an incredible
photograph Petra Collins took it young
photographer who's really talented and
the story which josh ellsworth one of
our writers he spent a great deal of
time with her I mean that that story I
think got to more depth about her and
her world than anything I've seen in
terms of profiles and pieces on her in
so far so that level of intimacy access
and depth is is key and very very
important to what we do but I would say
that the people that have been at the
company for that long are there because
they're very very talented and they
believe in the broader mission I mean if
you go top to bottom in our business you
look at the accountants like it
everyone's a music fan it's I mean I've
been at concerts and like seeing you
know someone from the accounting
department like way but it's it's
amazing everyone's connected by a love
for music and culture so I think that
makes Rolling Stone unique in terms of
retention of talent and people that work
at the brand but you know back to your
original question when you look at
magazines newspapers that have failed or
that are failing or going out of
business and the ones that are
succeeding or finding a path and a
strategy that will lead to success over
the next 5-10 years the the ones in the
latter group are ones that have been
very aggressive about you know making
the necessary moves and not kind of
timid about like changing the whole
model and changing the whole thinking
and culture let's hit the questions
again I want to make sure we get through
these here's one that's more music
oriented Lindsey let's hear this I'm mr.
wonderful and Gus I know you guys are
both great guitarists I've always wanted
to learn how to play the guitar but I've
never had enough time on
and now as you can imagine like most
people I have a lot do you have any
advice for somebody that's just starting
out with the guitar I've barely picked
up an instrument and I found a lot of
apps and whatnot online but I just need
some tips for a complete beginner
because honestly I have no idea where to
begin
thanks guys do you want to take this or
you want me to do well I think we should
both take it I've been playing guitar
since I was 13 and it's a [ __ ] you
never stop learning you have to play
every day you got to keep your calluses
and you have to
it's a [ __ ] that's what I think I'm
always frustrated that I can't be better
when I hear a guy like John Mayer play
whoo I know it just pisses me off so
much that he's a quantum from what I can
do and I'm never gonna get there that is
the nature of guitar it's quasi
frustrating how do you feel about it
well I think that in terms of learning
realizing that if you learn three chords
you can play like 80% of songs that
exist in the world it should be feel
like less of a mountain to climb because
if you if you learn the root chords one
four and five so like if you're in the
key of E EA and B you could really play
the majority of songs that you'd
probably want to play so I think if you
focus on learning those three chords G C
and D if you're in the key of G you'll
be able to do whatever you want for the
most part but then if you have big
ambitions like like mr. wonderful here
about playing like John Mayer you should
have started a long time ago I know but
I what I've come to is inclusion
listening to great guitarists that break
out and become iconic
you know there's playing the three
chords yeah I can do that but then
there's playing the guitar and adding
your own style to this so that the ear
defines who you are that's extremely
hard to do and I keep trying
I got a massive guitar collection I even
was a shareholder in fender for a while
and how crazy that is
but and by the way I made no money
guitars the why not here's a question
for you Gus why is a 1959 telly
I've got a 64 over here worth 40 times
that a brand new tele is and the new one
is way better from the electronic side
in the manufacturing process I'm talking
about a Stratocaster used to drive me
crazy
when I was a shareholder fender saying
why is a guy spending forty thousand
dollars on a 63 Stratocaster when he can
get one from us
brand-new for four thousand is 50 times
better what is the answer to that
question well I'm gonna answer it
understanding that I really don't know
what I'm talking about but I think it
goes back to the same reason why a
incredibly skilled technically
proficient guitar player who might be
technically speaking a better guitar
player than someone else who plays with
tons of soul and has their own style and
is interesting and you know you could
think of a million guitar players who
fit those two bills that that one that
is not maybe as good but just has such
an incredible style becomes iconic or
becomes a super successful guitar player
it's about the poetry of the instrument
and it's about the poetry of the sound
and not necessarily the technical
proficiency of the interest instrument
or the player yeah we as managers or
shareholders of that business we we were
we learned that it was a brutal truth I
wish I had had the foresight to keep 20%
of the production back in the 60s when I
was a kid
stored in a vault somewhere that would
have been an interesting outcome maybe
someone else will think of that alright
let's do another one here this is from
Craig hey Kevin this is Craig I have a
question for you
I said you're staying at home these days
do you still wake up every morning and
put on a suit or if you don't what would
be your quarantine powering fit you know
it's it's a good it's a good way to kind
of think about full circle on this I I
started this whole thing asking you Gus
what your routine was in this strange
time we're in and that's really what
this question is what do you do to keep
yourself saying
when you don't you could just wear your
pajamas all day do you have any routine
you do anything that makes your day have
definition versus just an endless stream
of walking around the same place I mean
in terms of the wardrobe I am suffering
from having calm out I'm in Long Island
right now my mom's house
I came out here the Friday before
quarantine was officially in place which
was a Monday so I literally have I have
three pairs of clothes so my optionality
is limited at the moment two of them
have like collars this shirt clearly
does not in terms of routine I look I'm
fortunate to be in a place that's their
space the ocean is nearby which has just
done wonders for me mentally and it's
amazing place to be quarantined and I'm
fortunate for that but I try to move I
try to get outside and move around for
at least an hour a day and get the blood
moving like some form of exercise timmy
is critical so I'm doing emails and
calls and the inflow of work has been
enormous through all this but finding an
hour in the morning or you know late
right before light goes down to be
outside and do something active has been
really critical to my routine I'd be
remiss if I didn't end on the topic of
musicians on musicians which is a very
successful print feature you did we met
as a result of exploring television
opportunities together why does that
format work and what is your hope if we
get together and do something on turn it
into television I mean the project
really intrigues me for my own reasons
but what is the genesis of how you got
it to be so I mean I've read them all
now I can't wait for another one I mean
they're just it's caviar of content
how did it come to be well we we came up
with the idea and basically I mean look
we did it we launched it last year as a
print digital well define what it is for
those listings I've never heard of it
before it's it is what it sounds like
it's two musicians interviewing one
another but we pair them with one of our
journalists who doesn't over insert
themselves in the conversation what kind
of guides it and I think that's a
critical piece to what made made it work
so well in year one and we also paired
really interesting people together we
weren't just like oh we're the two
people we can book we relied on our
relationships with with these
individuals and their teams and and
really thought of what would be the most
fascinating pairings so we had on on the
cover of this whole platform and I call
it a platform is not just a print thing
it's a big digital thing there's video
there's all sorts of elements to it but
we had on the cover Elton John and Lana
Del Rey interview one another and they
were there with one of our journalists
called Patrick Doyle who's fantastic and
you know he kind of kicked things off
and but Lana showed up with six pages of
notes of questions for Elton we had
Billie Eilish and Billie Joe Armstrong
together we had Lenny Kravitz and her we
had I think Bonnie Raitt was with Brandi
Carlile we had Maggie Rodgers we there
was such a wide range of people and such
interesting pairings and the
conversations were incredible they were
powerful they were funny and they were
always kind of guided and Shepherd along
bye-bye one of our our writers who was
there with them so it was a huge success
in year one the interest to participate
from the artists side and then from our
audience in terms of wanting more that
that series has been huge and turning it
into television seems like the natural
next step and it's just a great format
for it and ultimately the the vision is
to have these people covering each other
songs and I think that will raise it
even a notch higher and make it more
subsidy and rich and important so it's a
it's
great franchise and I hope we work on it
together
yeah me too I'm really excited about it
I hope it just it it's it's again
flexing your access muscle and your
brand muscle but in a way that is
completely different than anything I'd
seen before
I was I was reading the you know Ringo
Starr one and I mean it's it transcends
generations in a perfect way you
understand how you're passing the torch
as a musician from one to the next I
love that I love the format of it so I'm
very excited about it I hope Gus we work
on it together let's see what happens
listen thank you for your time we burned
up almost an hour it was just too
interesting to stop thank you for having
that you're a great you're a great
interview you don't [ __ ] so that's
that's that's different that's a little
different I try not do no but I often I
have to get out like a screwdriver pry
the truth out which I think I'm pretty
good at but I didn't have to do that
with you you just came came out so thank
you man I really I love a screwdriver
Kevin all right I'll talk to you soon
all right take care bye-bye
rock and roll baby
[Music]
requite wonder